Julie's in Dayton Ohio hi Julie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi there thanks
for taking my call
my pleasure what's up okay so I believe
in your system I'm working hard at it
I've listened to it for quite a long
time but you know in phases you go in
and out but I'm back right so I do pay
for everything with a debit card so I
don't owe anything except for my car in
my house and this is my dilemma
so I'm 58 when I retire sometime soon
you know five six seven years who knows
but I'm a realtor so I'll probably work
forever anyway but regardless I want to
be set up I did work for AT&T for 15
years so I do have like $200,000 in in
my my IRA and I do have social security
because I put my 35 years in this thing
on I'm saying so you know the 23
hundreds of max and of course they take
insurance out of that so it gets
whittled down a little bit depending on
the age I get that and then my dilemma
is I'd like to downscale I'd like to pay
cash for our house I went to them for a
while five eight years and I hit it
pretty big I had about 150 sales there
and kept that cash put some in my IRA
and then paid cash I don't understand
why you have a dilemma what's the
dilemma my dilemma as we bought a four
hundred and fifteen thousand dollar
house and I put 225 down on it what's
your household income probably two
hundred thousand I am a collisional
person well that's that's the thing I
mean you can't pay it off overnight
shouldn't I just downscale now
no you make $200,000 a year you have a
great house only owe two hundred
thousand on it you're 58 but you're 58
by the time you're 63 have it paid for
okay yeah but I've been worried about
that you couldn't like your house I love
my house and my husband's older but he's
a great shape and everything and his
income is guaranteed good
be a security and Union Colleen I work
very hard for it how old is he he's very
very young 77 okay and when he does all
this money dies right that's that's
right okay that leaves you with 350 and
I shown no life insurance correct but I
have the 350 plus another hundred plus
my plus you make time your household
incomes 200 as long as he lives
okay right but I also have my I have two
rentals so in my house
what are they were together probably
together about a hundred thousand okay
all right well here's what I would do I
would work diligently to pay off your
home and between the two and the both of
you agree on that and say okay five
years from today he's going to be 82
you're gonna be 63 we need to have this
thing paid for if we do not and he
passes away you may want to downsize
well and I can downsize any one of my
rentals because that was our home before
we went to this home well maybe my god I
don't care about that but the point is
you may not be you don't may need to be
sitting on a big mortgage if all of his
income leaves no no I don't that's what
I want but you can always make that
decision if he were to pass away if he
lives five years and you live five years
in the house is paid for your set right
yeah so let's not sell it today unless
you just hate it
no I do love it I wanted to sell it he
doesn't want to tell it he loves it
right well live there I mean and and he
can live there as long as he lives to
stay in the houses stay alive yeah I'm
getting old so old jokes are working for
me these days
I'm feeling bad about it because I
wanted to pay cash I want you to pay it
off okay and I want you quit spending
money on a bunch of other stupid stuff
and you don't need another car get that
car paid off and then let's start then
you and he together go okay
there's two hundred thousand here five
years that's forty thousand bucks out of
two hundred out of two hundred thousand
you need to be doing that or more if you
fifty thousand a year extra on the house
out of your two hundred thousand that's
four years the house is paid for alright
that's a great way to look at it by the
way I'll Drive at I Drive a Jeep not a
Cherokee I know but you ran statements
on it and you're 58 I know
pay it off pay it off and don't you dare
go buy something else on payments don't
you you haven't got time fall off the
wagon again sister you need to ride the
wagon now ride it all the way out okay
but that plan will work for you you're
doing good you guys got a great income
as long as he lives so um you know then
if you get in a pinch you can always
sell it later
and I'm gonna stay there and see if this
works good question